Let's do a few more examples of
solving radical equations.
Let's say I have the square root
of x plus 2 minus 2 is
equal to 0.
So just like I said in the last
video, we always want to
isolate the radical.
And the best way I can think
of doing it over here, is
adding 2 to both sides
of this equation.
So if you add 2 to both sides of
this equation, we are left
with the square root of x plus
2-- on the left-hand side this
cancels out --is equal to 2.
And once you isolate one of
the radicals, then you're
ready to essentially, square
both sides of this.
If we're dealing with a
square root, we square
both sides of this.
Let's do that.
So let's square both sides
of that equation.
And then we get-- square root of
x plus 2 squared is just x
plus 2 is equal to 2 squared.
Is equal to 4.
Subtract 2 from both sides
of this equation.
We're left with x-- these 2's
cancel out --is equal to 2.
Now let's validate that this
is truly the case.
That it works when we're taking
the principal root, not
both square roots or the
negative square root.
Let's see, when we take the
principal root we get the
square root of 2-- that's our
answer --plus this 2, minus 2,
should be equal to 0.
This is 4.
The principal root of 4 is 2.
2 minus 2 does indeed equal 0.
So this is a valid solution.
It's not an extraneous
solution.
It works with the
principal root.
Let's do one that doesn't
involve a square root.
Let's do one with a
higher power root.
Let's say we have the fourth
root of x squared minus 9 is
equal to 2.
So you say, gee, Sal,
what do I do here?
Fourth root?
That's crazy.
How do we deal with
the fourth root?
And it's the same process.
When you had a square
root we squared it.
When you have the fourth
root, we take it
to the fourth power.
And just as a bit of a review,
this could be completely
written like this.
Another way to write it would
be x squared minus 9 to the
1/4 power is equal to 2.
These are equivalent statements,
just different
ways of writing the
fourth root.
Now, if we raise both sides to
the fourth power, what happens
to this exponent right here?
If we raise something to an
exponent, and then raise that
to another exponent, we multiply
the exponents.
So 1/4 times 4 is 1.
So this just becomes x squared
minus 9 to the first power.
Or we could just write
x squared minus 9.
And that's going to be equal
to 2 to the fourth power.
2 to the fourth power
is, what?
2 times 2 is 4.
Times 2 is 8.
Times 2 is 16.
There's two ways we can do it
actually at this point.
We can add 9 to both sides
of this equation.
I'll do it this way in yellow.
So if you add 9 you get x
squared is equal to 25.
Take the square root, not just
the principal square root,
take the positive and negative
square root of both sides of
this equation and you get x is
equal to plus or minus 5.
That's one way.
The other way-- sometimes it's
confusing, people forget to
take the positive and negative
square roots --is to do it the
way we've been doing all along
through solving traditional
quadratics, setting
them equal to 0.
So what you do is you subtract
16 from both
sides of this equation.
If you do that you get x
squared minus 25, if we
subtract 16 from both sides,
is equal to 0.
So these two are equivalent.
Essentially, we're just
moving the 25 onto
the left-hand side.
We're just subtracting
25 from both sides
of this to get that.
But what this does is it puts us
in the form of a difference
of squares.
We know we can rewrite this as
x plus 5 times x minus 5.
We went over that several
videos ago.
And that will be equal to 0.
And if the product of two
numbers is equal to 0, that
means that either one or both
of them is equal to 0.
So x plus 5 is equal to 0 or
x minus 5 is equal to 0.
And we get x is equal to
negative 5 or x is equal to
positive 5, which is what
we got right there.
Now, the one thing we want to
make sure once again, is that
neither of these are extraneous
solutions.
Because when you're taking a
fourth root or when you take
something to the fourth
power, negative
numbers also disappear.
You can kind of view it as a
principal fourth root that
we're taking here.
A negative version of this could
have also been valid.
So let's make sure that
they both work.
Well, whether we put negative
5 or positive 5 here, this
right here is going to be 25.
So you get the fourth root of
25 minus 9, which is the
fourth root of 16.
So this is the fourth root of
16, which is equal to 16 to
the 1/4 power.
Which is indeed, 2.
So both of these work.
When you square either of these,
you do indeed, get 25.